Chicago right now because they're a
sanctuary City and they're already
struggling for the reasons we've just
laid out right Generations post welfare
state uh they're not too happy the black
residents of Chicago uh that they're
about to get 250 to 500 illegals being
busted into their neighborhoods as we
speak take a look
it's important is that we really
established that this is a humanitarian
crisis and we're here
South Shore residents responded with
resounding rejection
while this crisis May constant
constant South Shore Community
incoming migrants have overwhelmed
District police stations by the hundreds
it's my turn it's my turn hello but city
leaders could barely eke out a word of
the details about a proposed Respite
Center at the former South Shore High
School when it comes to the total number
of people at South Shore at any given
point in time it is fluid we'd start
with 250 500.
did you do that without consulting us I
am concerned with safety in the area it
continued here's some residents
explaining why they do not want these
people there and it is their god-given
right not to have them there because
we're supposed to have a border
all these resources that have not come
to us now you want to overly compensate
for people who never lived here before
and they need to be taken care of first
and foremost before anything else
happens here right yeah
why would any leader put our black
communities already riddled with crime
at further risk by placing unvetted
non-taxpayers steps away from our city
our seniors our children and our homes
we've worked so hard on our own to
secure
we are at War people
our communities are at War
they are violating our communities and
we asking that we have we across the
country we asking them with demanding
for office of Black America or whatever
you want to call it to deal with issues
like this
uh I did get placed on the waitlist but
I was told that the immigrants were
taking priorities
dude that's a story that a lot of people
don't know and it just it hurt me I'm
like oh wait a minute
I understand we need to be humanitarian
but these people are that my
participants are third and fourth
generation Chicagoans born bred fed and
raised here they want Law and Order in
their communities they want their public
officials to take care of them before
they take care of illegal people so
they're asking the they're asking the
very very basics
[Music]
oh